an extreme heat wave is creating
dangerous conditions across much of the
country the Northeast broke several heat
records over the weekend today
temperatures will soar into the 90s and
it's gonna feel like triple digits
Philadelphia issued a health emergency
advising people to limit their time
outdoors more than 50 million Americans
are under excessive heat warnings and
the heat wave is expected to continue as
the July 4th holiday approaches oh joy
DeMarco Morgan is along the shore in
Long Branch New Jersey where is expected
to feel like 100 degrees today
DeMarco good morning and lucky you yeah
I know right this is an amazing sign but
here good morning to you Gail as well
I hear along the New Jersey Shore it's
all about the temperature and the heat
index combined in some of the hottest
spots it's gonna feel more like it's a
hundred and five degrees
that's why fischels are warning people
to take extra precautions and to stay
hydrated across the Northeast from
beaches to parks people are searching
for relief from the simmering
temperatures this is a little extreme
but I'll take it over snow any day and
Boston city officials declared a heat
emergency sent it out notifications to
senior citizens and opening cooling
stations across the city we're asking
people not to go on long walks and not
to choose any type of exercise
particularly with the heat avoiding
exercise what's impossible for the
nearly 5,000 participants of the New
York City triathlon yesterday race
organizers took precautions to keep
runners cool and medical staff were
on-hand for emergencies and to remind
them to stay hydrated you know when
these racers tend to just put their head
down and keep going really hard they
sometimes forget that in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania fire captain Alden Morelli
used field temperature gauges about 143
degrees right there to demonstrate the
dangers of leaving any person or animal
in a locked car doctors are urging
people to be aware of the warning signs
in order to avoid a heatstroke you start
to feel a little nauseous kind of a
little bit weak and almost dizzy and
those are really the warning signs like
it's time to get out of the heat now
just to be on the safe side New York
City has set up cooling stations
throughout the
city throughout the 4th of July holiday
which is about as long as this heatwave
is expected to last Anthony DiMarco
thanks a brutal one